Let's divide 9,815
by 65, or figure out
how many times the
65 go into 9,815.
And I encourage you
to pause this video
and try this on your own.
So let me just rewrite this
as 9,815 divided by 65.
And we write it this
way because it's easier
to manipulate the
numbers, kind of doing
the standard process here.
And as we'll see,
whenever we divide
by a number that has
more than one digit,
there's a little
bit of an art to it.
And hopefully you'll
get an appreciation
for that art over the
course of this video.
So first we could
think about well,
how many times
does 65 go into 9?
Well it doesn't go
into 9 at all so we
can move one digit to the right.
How many times does it go
into 98 without going over it?
Well 65 times 1 is 65 so
that doesn't go over it.
And 65 times 2, well
that would be 130 so
that would go over 98.
So it only goes one time.
We multiply 1 times
65, which is 65.
And then we could subtract to
see how much we have left over.
So 8 minus 5 is 3
and 9 minus 6 is 3.
And now we can bring down
the next digit, this 1 here.
And now this is where
the art is going
to come into play because
we need to figure out
how many times does 65 go into
331 without going over it.
And you might just try
to look at these numbers,
try to approximate
them a little bit.
You might say, well, maybe 65,
let me round this thing up.
Maybe this is close to 70.
And let's see, this
is close to 300.
So maybe we say, well,
70 would go into 300.
So maybe we think about how
many times does 70 go into 300?
And we say without
going over it,
it doesn't go exactly into 300.
Well you could say, well how
many times does 7 go into 30?
Well we know 7 goes
into 30 four times.
4 times 7 is 28.
So maybe try a 4 right
over here because then this
will be 280, 4 times 70 is 280.
You're still going to have
a little bit left over,
but what you have left over
is going to be less than 70.
It's going to be 20.
So you say, well, if
this is roughly 70
and if this is roughly
300, then maybe it's
going to be the same thing.
So let's try that out.
Let's see if it goes four times.
So 4 times 5 is 20, carry the 2.
4 times 6 is 24 plus 2 is 26.
And now let's see how
much we had left over.
So when we subtract,
we are left with-- I'll
do this in a new
color-- 1 minus 0 is 1.
We have a 3 here and
a 6 here so we're
going to have to do
a little regrouping.
Let's take 100 from
the hundreds place.
It becomes 200.
Give those 10 tens, that
100, to the tens place.
So now we have 13 tens.
13 minus 6 is 7 and
then 2 minus 2 is 1.
So did this work out?
Well no, our remainder, after
we said it went in four times,
we actually had 71 left over.
71, this right over
here, is larger than 65.
You don't want a situation
where what you have left over
is larger than
what you're trying
to divide into the number.
You could have gone
into it one more
time because you had
so much left over.
So this 4 was actually too low.
We should have probably
approximated this as 60,
and 60 goes into 300,
if we were to estimate,
we'd say, well that might
be closer to five times.
So this is where the art
of this comes into play.
So it was very reasonable to
do what I just did, but it just
turned out to not be the
right way to think about it.
I could just say, well
the 4 wasn't enough.
I had too much left over.
Let me try 5 now.
5 times 5 is 25, carry the 2.
5 times 6 is 30, plus 2 is 32.
There you go.
We got much closer to
331 without going over.
Now we can subtract.
And once again, we could
do a little regrouping.
Take a 10 from the tens place.
This becomes two tens.
This becomes an 11.
11 minus 5 is 6, 2 minus
2 is 0, 3 minus 3 is 0.
So we only have 6
left over, which
is obviously less than 65.
So we're all good.
And if we put a 6 here, we
would have gone over 331.
And so that wouldn't
have been cool either.
But anyway, let's bring
down the next digit.
Let's bring down the 5.
So how many times
does 65 go into 65?
Well, it goes one time.
1 times 65,-- OK.
Ignore this, that's from
a previous step-- 1 times
65 is 65.
And then you subtract,
and we have no remainder.
So we see that 65 goes into
9,815 exactly 150-- let me
just that in that
same blue color,
I don't want to do all these
arbitrary colors-- 151 times.